[音楽]
anitta
[拍手]
私は仕事柄よくコーヒー思います
たとえは焙煎したての珈琲を
カッピングといって
そのスプーンを使って
液体がをチュウチュウとスって提出にします
また店頭では
まりされてクレーター s best
チェックしたりまた
店頭でお出しする
新コーヒーの味わいをチェックしたい
時には産地から送らてくるかいつ経産婦の豆をこのキャッピングで
強化したいっ
その時は頭の中をコーヒーの情報がグーハケメ軍ですね
うんこのコーヒーは
中米グアテマラバー
上やてな事言う産地の応援で
品種はパカマラん
標高1800m
メキシコ今日から流れる風は山の斜面にあたりそのテロワールは独特なフレーバーを
運びます
belly up マンゴーの2に
ダークチョコ
フローラな余韻
まろやかな口あたり長く続く珈琲館
100点満点で93点なんてですね
超常連の山下さんの満足するような笑顔が目に浮かぶんですね
もちろんそんな仕事をグラムではなく1日のはじまり
また仕事の合間とかおいしくコーヒーを楽しめます
皆さんもよくコーヒー飲まれたい
多いのかなと思いますがもしはさっきの私みたいね
このコーヒーは中米グアテマラのとか言って生まれ方は少ないと思います
それでも香り味を楽しみながら
りらくしたタイムをおいしくそうされていることと思います
そんな時皆さんの表情は
とても穏やかな
映画じゃないかなと思うんですね
そんな私たちを癒してくれるコーヒー
産地は赤道直
そして
経済的には裕福なとこばかりでありません
中米だぞ買い付けていきますと
空港についてそれから数時間車で地域の街まで移動し
そしてそれからまた男と富山市を登って山から山へ
やっと
農園につきます
そこで働く人たちは先住民
家族宮でお家に住み込んで農作業にあたっています
厳しい環境
私は僕の生活その中でも私たちを素敵な笑顔で迎えてくれるんですね
特に
子どもたち
子どもたちは
元気だ
笑顔で素晴らしいんですね
そこには私たちが日本人が
忘れかけている
物質的な豊かさそれだけでも大に何かがあるように思います
その私ですが仕事は
父が創業した
日本茶お茶の販売店でした
オンリーワンの商品を釣りたいというのが自家焙煎珈琲を始めるきっかけです
1999年小型の焙煎機を導入します
自家焙煎珈琲を始めましたと
大きな声で言いたいんですがなかなか自分が考えるような思えなコーヒー作りができ
ません
なんせ珈琲屋で修行したこともないし
20年間落ちないでずっとやってましたね
それでもセミナーに出たり専門書を読んだり
またインターネットで
情報を得てそして試行錯誤
暗中模索の日々をつけます
そんな折であったのが全国から須藤自家焙煎店グループ
コーヒー飲み方宿でした
彼らはすでにもう is 下にいました
当時まだ聞き慣れなかったスペシャルティコーヒーに特化ししかもその生豆を自分たち
で勝者を盗撮
産地から直接買い付けを始めていました
そのグループに運良く参加ができたのが2003年です
2ヵ月に1回
ネイバー点を持ち回りで勉強会が開催されます
内容は買い付けのためのカッピング
焙煎抽出農園情報そしてマーケティング
そしてカッピングカップにカップです
コーヒづくりの根幹となるカッピングをとことん
教えていただきますまたそのシェアは海外にも広がり
アメリカスペシャルティコーヒー協会の大会や展示会セミナーにも参加しました
そんなアトランタやシアトルに行き始めたのはこの子です
私の
全エネルギーをコーヒ作りに
注ぎ込んだっ
そんな2005年ある
例年解析をしていました中でぇー許され buzz
音程しょん農園の子供たち
人たちにクリスマスプレゼントを贈ろうという話が用いられました
私たちはみんなでを願う詰めてそして何を買おうか迷ったんですが結局はお金を送りし
ました
それから1年を育ってまたその農園を訪問します
私たちはは大歓迎を受けます
頭に案内され
部屋に入っていくとそこにはパネルがあって
ここには子どもたちのための医療活動の様子があります
また
正面には
プロジェクターで大きく書いてあります
そこには鉛筆にーくらー
ノートに文房具に行く
そうです
あのクリスマスプレゼントでお送りしたお金の使い道
その内訳書いてあったんですん
そして
農園主の女性
ウルティアさんは
2人のを子どもたちを前に呼び
この子等があなたがたのクリスマスプレゼントで
学校に行けたよと優しい笑顔で紹介してくれたんです
2人も
無茶するらしいですはにかみながらお礼を言っているんですね
私たちは感激しました
あのお金がこんなにお役に立ったんだ
そしてそのと気づいたんです
日本人個人としてはわずかな金額かもしれないけど
こんなにお金でもらえる
そして
コーヒー豆の買い付けを通して
生産者
産地の人々に大いなる貢献できる
桃
すぐに
確信いたしました
個人グループ
思いを源として表示します
高品質コーヒーの会計その基準は変わりませんが
寺駅重視だけではなく
生活環境
どうぞ環境自然環境
ポン酢配慮した農園主生産車イス業者の方々とのお付き合いが始まっています
作り手売り手買い手三者が偏った力関係ではなく
お互いにリスペクトし
サステイナブル持続可能な関係です
また他の国々でも
それぞれにプロジェクトが動き始めました
そんな頃あの労働者思いのうち屋さんからまた連絡が入ります
今度は農園で働く小さなお母さんたちのために託児所を作りたいと言われるんです
もちろんグループ
ジェミン戦勝となりました
メンバーの中にはもうテーション支援しルってのを作って自分で販売したり
まだ私も自身自分自身の思いだけではなくお客様にも一緒にこの前につながって
いただこうという考えで
豆の売り上げあたり客グアムにあたり10円をお客様から10膳をお店から拠出し
送らさせていただきました
グループでもう来なく金額となり無事に託児所は完成します
ウルティアさんもまた小さな子供を背負ったん
お母さんたちもへ
大勢にも述べました
このような貢献支援は私個人
1人では到底できなかったと思います
買い付けグループがあったからこそできたんですね
現在でば構成スタイル名称も
ジャパンロースターズネットはと変わりましたが勉強会
またその思いは
継続されています
私のような未熟な
この仲間に入れてくれたメンバーそしてご指導いただいている先生には心より
感謝しております
このように
コーヒー豆の買い付けを通して
誓った思い
そうスタンスは
それ以外にも展開していきます
ておきますこれ
がたまらの民族いっしょその布地をリサイクルして作ってもです
2人の日本人女性がグアテマラの人々に貢献したりそんな思いで
会社を立ち上げます
現地に工房を作り現地の人を雇い入れ
そして日本で販売するそんな
ビジネス戻りです私もそれに共感し
コラボデー
作ってもらいました
重いと思いがつながってまた新しい笑顔があるんですね
私はこれからも一コーヒーやとして
そして
生産者
消費者
その薬となりー
歩んでいきたいと思っています
そして最後に
この1杯のコーヒーデー
すべての人々がスマイル
笑顔になりませんありございました
[拍手]